ladies and gentlemen Star Tribune
reports Derek Chavin trial court
adjourned for the day jury selection
expected to begin to Tuesday unless
appeals court intervenes they say
motions were reviewed during a short
one-hour session in the afternoon case
resumes Thursday is that jury selection
was delayed for at least a day in the
murder case against Joven uh charged
with killing George Floyd Hennepin
County District Attorney judge Peter
Cahill said he wants to hear from the
state court of appeals about the
prosecution's desire to revive a third
degree murder charge to the counts of
second-degree murder and manslaughter in
Floyd's death last May which was
captured captured by on a bystander cell
phone and broadcast around the world
Cahill who threw out the disputed count
last fall said the prospective jurors
home for the day ahead of bringing them
oh he sent the progressive jurors home
today ahead of bringing them back on
Thursday
this is where we're at so far and
outside of this news about the delay we
also have they've set up barricades
already 2 000 National Guard being
called in this is always the craziest
thing I'm like when you know we're
putting these videos together and trying
to figure out what the the right title
should be it's like do we mention two
thousand National Guard called into
Minneapolis because they're scared
people are going to go crazy or do we
just give you like the straight facts
and I was like let's just you know let's
avoid the like the uh you know National
Guards coming to get you but I think
it's fair to say no matter what happens
I think we'll see riots you know I don't
know I don't know what you think it's uh
it's it's not going to end well I mean
there was a I wish I remembered his name
but there was a guy who wrote a piece on
medium um way way around the time that
all this stuff was was going on and he
mentioned you know it's it's a part of
the mpd's code like they're allowed to
to use the knee on the neck or something
like that in in terms of restraint and
uh I mean his his whole argument was
that it's likely that Chauvin is not
going to be convicted a first degree
murder I just don't think these charges
are going to stick I think second second
they're trying to add third so I mean I
just I don't know how these charges will
stick but it's also
I mean this this is a huge sticking
point for me because it's yet another in
this Litany of stories that involve law
enforcement and a black person uh being
being killed that
um that are completely distorted by by
the press and you you take this string
of incidents are you or you create this
string of incidents you know you don't
look at them on an individual basis you
know for me the Eric Garner case that
was more of a gray area but then you
have like the Walter Scott case where he
got shot in the back and it's a
clear-cut case of of murder I think I
think that cop is actually serving uh 20
years was that the one where the guy was
running away
pulled it bam and shot it right like
that kind of stuff you're like you know
I think I think the philando Castile um
I'm shooting was also a bad shoot but
there's but the NRA that was the that
was on where he had he legally owned a
gun oh right right right right right and
the cop panicked and shot him anyway
that made me angry because I was like
the NRA should have been out here in two
seconds right we'll see and here's the
thing on top of that because there are
there are many channels on YouTube that
upload nothing but a police body Cam and
dash cam footage so you can I mean I've
seen Howard I've seen a lot of people
get shot but you can see hours and hours
of what police have to deal with all the
time and when you and when you begin to
see for instance how a a routine traffic
stop that can be uh friendly you know
Pleasant can turn deadly like that you
know or you see uh I mean the idea of
sending social workers to handle you
know for instance like the the capital
Insurrection you know well I mean it's
just because you know when when you see
enough videos of like a six foot five
you know dude who's in some kind of
psychosis or he's on drugs or something
and you know they try tasers they don't
work they try beanbag grounds they don't
work they try I mean people they're
emptying their magazines into this
person and they still don't you know
what I mean it's just there's so many
more layers and there's so many more
things that you that you have to
consider that people just don't consider
when dealing with the police you know
what I mean take any one of these people
to a firing range and then give them a
handgun and watch them completely change
their opinions on all this stuff yeah so
I I recently was talking to some friends
and explaining to them the first the
first time I ever went to a shooting
range it was during the Ferguson riots
I've mentioned this so you know fans of
the show probably are familiar with the
story they said the first thing was have
you ever fired a gun before if you
haven't we don't want you to go in there
without without someone to train you and
give you the basics and so I said I
hadn't but the guy I was with was like
this hardcore War journalist who's fired
full auto you know AKs in the
Philippines and other crazy countries so
he was like don't worry we'll we'll
teach him how to fire a Glock no problem
and my aim was actually no my my aim was
awful but I was consistent I aimed for
the chest and the target at seven yards
and I hit him in the groin every time
but that's true story true story uh I
was like I was very aware of how I was
holding my body and I could I could
repeat that same position but I was just
shooting low every time and they told me
I was probably pulling my hand down when
I was pulling the trigger and they tried
giving these pointers
what they told me was the average person
that they give a handgun to can't hit
the target at seven yards and believe it
or not the other people who were with us
they couldn't hit this thing I was I was
amazed by like how bad everyone's
accuracy was now you imagine you're what
20 yards away the MythBusters did this
thing where they're like a person with a
knife can close 21 yards before the cop
can get his gun out so the the average
person in a panic situation a cop even
with certification of some sort it's a
high intensity moment he's freaking out
he's adrenaline rushing and he goes for
his gun and the guy's already closed the
Gap yeah and if the guy's further away
than that he's got to be pretty good
proficient with his weapon people don't
realize man there's a reporter who did
who you can find this video on YouTube
who was very much you know he was on
that Narrative of like you know you know
anti-police and all this stuff and and
he went and under the and underwent the
training and that exact scenario you
know someone and there's again there's
videos online that you can find of
people with a knife and you know they
you know they might be across the room
or something like that and the officer
will get stabbed several times before
his partner is able to to draw and take
the guy down I'm like there's there's
but this reporter was like oh his mind
totally changed because he saw just how
dangerous somebody can be with a knife I
mean there was that shooting recently
was it in Philadelphia where the guy had
the knife and people were like he
shouldn't have been shot I'm like dude
you just he was on he was he was having
some kind of of mental I don't know if
the politically correct term is
psychosis or an episode episode let's go
with that and um Andy had a knife and
when you've when you've seen hours and
hours of this stuff and you see how it
turns out you know it it it's one thing
if you have an issue with police using
lethal Force you know I I could actually
respect that position if you have an
ethical problem with it I'm just glad
you're not a cop but if you're trying to
say well they should never ever in under
any circumstances use I'm like dude
sorry man that's just not how life works
it's not how life works you are divorced
from reality I cannot ask in good
conscience a cop to go out there knowing
there are risks and I don't mean all the
time it's not you know I'm sure they're
they're going to be on edge in many
circumstances it's not like every day
they go out there you know on the verge
of dying but it is a lottery ticket
where if you get those numbers right you
get a bullet and so I'm not going to ask
someone to buy that ticket unless I give
them the opportunity to protect
themselves in the event the ticket comes
due you know what I mean so I see I see
these cops who go out there and I think
we need police reform I think we've got
issues with police accountability I I've
explained to Chicago always be better
absolutely and at the same time we just
had this video go viral where a woman I
guess the story was a woman asked these
cops to come in and protect her as she
was going into her home because she was
worried about an ax who was armed and so
the cops are like he has a weapon let us
know where the weapon is and there it
seems like they're with her to practice
woman dude barges in the door and starts
shooting like crazy
this is a reality man when when when you
have to deal with the like the violence
and the anger and so here's what what
ends up happening is
we're asking cops to end of the
situation but we're also asking them to
essentially throw themselves in the
sacrificial dagger in the event that
something goes wrong so you have I think
the the George Floyd thing was a very
very tragic case with a whole lot of
problems and I do think that uh Chauvin
Bears some responsibility for this
that's why I said manslaughter may
actually be uh an actual outcome and the
reason for it he he remained on the neck
three minutes after Floyd was
unresponsive and so maybe you argue that
the training says that's what you're
supposed to do because it allows them to
breathe maybe your argument is he should
have set him up and then provided
rendered eight or something
the challenge is you know let's like I
said they might actually say
manslaughter like you know you could
have done something you were the one who
restrained him and the restraint was
part of the you know there's a reason
for death but you have many
circumstances where well let me start by
saying this you have many circumstances
where cop cops grew up philando Castile
legal gun owner in his car telling the
cop I do have my legal gun and the cop
panics and shoots him anyway that's
messed up but then you have you know
these circumstances where in that one
viral video where these two cops are
trying to subdue a guy and then he runs
to his door grabs the gun and just
shoots both these cops like crazy
that's that's real life these things
happen I think is that the video where
the one cops just starts this he lets
out this blood curdling shriek and then
it's just silent after he gets I mean
yeah that's that's some chilling stuff
it is but you have to but you have but
you have to be aware of that kind of
thing and that kind of danger before you
can really offer any sort of nuanced
opinion on these kinds of matters and
now think about it so for for all the
things I've seen wrong like you
mentioned was the Michael Scott case
yeah Walter Scott Walter Scott sorry
yeah Michael Scott is from the office
yes great actor
uh Walter Scott was running away and the
cop just looks and then puts a bull in
his back he went to prison for that he
got held accountable I'm glad to hear it
for all these other stories you got to
understand the nuance and the way I
usually put it is I hear the left say oh
the likelihood they get shot or whatever
is Slim than none and I'm like I I don't
know I hear you I hear you so what
you're saying is you think these guys
should take a job that doesn't pay very
well has crappy hours and every day is a
lottery ticket where if their number
comes due they die I'm sorry man I'm
gonna give them a weapon and say in the
event that happens because we're asking
you to do this on our behalf you defend
yourselves and that means there's going
to be some some there's going to be
accidents there's going to be bad people
and it means it's a part of life we got
we got to figure it out when when that
dude shot you know Walter Scott in the
back he got arrested and charged for it
he got he got held accountable
thankfully because of video so we need
to make sure we're being reasonable in
the event with George Floyd I think it's
I think it's interesting I think they
overcharged the guide yeah and I think
the the activists want
retribution I don't think Justice is the
right word for it the question is was he
defending himself I agree with you
because it's their job is they need to
defend themselves but was was Chauvin
defending himself he wasn't it didn't
seem like it no and and I I definitely
think the media in the left makes it out
to be substantially worse than it was
especially after we saw the body camera
footage Floyd saying take me out put me
on the ground put me on the ground
things like that but I do think there is
a legitimate question where we can have
a debate about manslaughter not murder
the murder charges I think are going to
fall off because I think third degree
murder is that you intended to cause
harm that resulted in death but I don't
think look so we can pull this up we
have this tweet from Brandon Stahl you
can actually see this is from the MPD
training manual apparently it shows the
cops putting their knee on the neck of
another officer it's not a real uh you
know submission this is a training video
YouTube Don't demonetize us this is this
is the police training material you can
see they're trained to do this yeah and
they're told to do it because they say
place the subject in the recovery
position to alleviate positional
asphyxia the point of putting their knee
on the neck is specifically to stop them
from suffocating
the question is George Floyd was put in
the custody of these officers when when
the officers assume custody of an
individual they have a responsibility
now they have responsibility to make
sure that they're not causing the person
harm or creating undue stress and you
know checking on this individual
I will say there isn't a tough question
is because it was a matter of uh it was
nine minutes to me that's crazy that's a
long time to be kneeling on somebody
nine minutes but it was three minutes
where float was unresponsive
what was what should he have done and
what was he doing and what is what are
the real questions we're trying to ask
ultimately I'm not sure prison solves
anything maybe maybe he gets kicked off
the force because they were like we need
people who aren't going to be they're
going to be more attuned to this but
prison time I mean I think that's bold
uh
I mean
it prison time it might make some people
feel better but I mean let's be real no
matter how this shakes out which you
know I think we're all in agreement that
it's not going to be what a lot of
people wanted the people seeking
retribution wanted to be and you know we
I think they want first degree murder
but you know what they're already primed
now because as soon as as the Lesser
charges go through they're going to say
this is yet another instance of of the
racist uh system in America you know uh
being unjust toward toward black
Americans and um you know I I I'm trying
to
Stave off uh this this creeping nihilism
but you know there there are a lot of
instances where I feel like you know
there's just you can't
I should I guess I shouldn't say can't
but it I don't I just don't know how you
how you walk back from all of this the
generation well this is what's funny
because I tend to be more pessimistic
but I also feel like well if you become
demoralized and you become depressed
then they whoever they is
um they then they win right but then you
know I mean I I'm I spend a lot of time
down in Atlanta now and um you know at
my job which I which I I won't mention
because I don't you know I don't want
people to to track me down and be crazy
but you know it's my job to enforce a
dress code let's let's say that and so
the minute that somebody shows up and
they're not in dress code and they
happen to to not be white they
immediately jump to well well you're
racist even though and then they then
they're like what about that person Oh
you mean that black person wearing a
Blazer and dress shoes that is in dress
code okay if there are black people
inside then how is it racist that you
can't get inside but that's where people
that's where their mind jumps down this
is do they call you racist yeah oh oh
Uncle Tom they you know they call me a
house negro because if they don't they
use the other inward
um you know it's just the most one of
the guys I work with is South Africa I'm
like how much blacker can you get than
someone from after Africa and yet they
call him the same kind of things when
he's when he you know we're just taking
these rules about power but it's but
it's deeper than that though because
you know I think about the the average
life of a say a black kid in America and
you know they wake up in the morning
they go to school and what are their
Educators telling them oh America is
racist you know Civil War Abe Lincoln
MLK they you know their favorite
athletes their favorite comedians their
favorite musicians they all have this
same sort of message they go on social
media they watch the news it's the same
message it's you know their their
relatives their friends and family are
all saying the same things to them so
this is a constant inundation of this
world view that says that white people
are evil America is racist and this is
generations and generations now and uh
you know again in my darker moments I
say how do you combat that you know and
and you know someone like someone like
me comes along and here's and here's
another irony of it because when I was a
kid it was the other you know people
think that I was born with a silver
spoon in my mouth that is not true at
all but you know I grew up in you know
around working class you know sort of
more on the poor and poor poorer end of
things and because of the way I carry
myself the fact that I had the temerity
to turn in my homework on time or at
least to try I was accused of acting
white and now what's happening is that
you have this educated class now this
intelligentia this Bourgeois class or
whatever of of white but also black
people who are also saying the same
things about you know if you're punctual
if you're disciplined if you're a rugged
individualist then you're striving for
whiteness if you're looking for a a
financial success or whatever then
you're striving for whiteness so now
you're getting it from the bottom and
from the top as well and so I don't know
where you you have to find some way to
break out of that and escape from it and
I don't know what those Avenues are for
people thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segment
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time